j'ai pas dormi depuis deux jours à les
amis j'ai découvert une histoire
formidable connaissez vous l'histoire du
pain maudit de pont-saint-esprit vous en
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
puisque ces derniers mois la sphère est
sorti un peu dans quelques médias et
surtout elle fait sensation parce que le
mystère n'a toujours pas été expliquées
de quel mystère vais-je par les
attendait soyez patients comment son
histoire connaissez-vous la ville de
pont-saint-esprit
moi je connaissais pas avoir cette
histoire pour être franc avec vous il
s'agit d'une petite ville du sud de la
france en 1958 à environ 4000 habitants
il y avait trois médecins ce qui est pas
beaucoup d'affaires médecins pour 1000
personnes faut pas avoir une angine en
même temps c'est assez rural s'agit
essentiellement de la viticulture et la
ville est très connu pour son bon
tellement connue pour son pont que le
mot pont et même dans le nom de la ville
pourquoi le point connu parce que
l'histoire raconte qu'il aurait été
construit par le saint-esprit contre la
volonté du diable qui ne voulait pas
qu'il y ait de bons alors je pense que
si ces deux entités existent elles sont
bat un peu et quid d'un pont après c'est
mon avis mais petit problème le pont a
été bombardé par les américains pendant
la guerre et du coup il ya plus de
pompes donc les habitants les spiritains
je crois il s'appelle spirit in his prix
merde ils sont plus trop fier parce que
ce fameux pont et détruit même si l'on
construise un provisoire mais voilà tout
ça c'est juste pour contextualiser un
peu ce que c'est que cette ville d'où
elle sort ce qui s'y passe etc
on va maintenant s'intéresser à des
faits qui sont survenus dans les années
50 dans la ville et qui sont fassions
dans le 2 août 1951 plusieurs personnes
vont chez le médecin et se plaignent de
douleurs gastriques et de malaise même
pour certains bons ces symptômes pas
très graves qui peuvent arriver
pour plusieurs raisons le médecin
conclut qui a eu un toxique à sion
élémentaires dont killer prescrit une
tisane de grand mère et puis ça devrait
aller mieux sauf que c'est pas le cas la
situation s'aggrave quand quatre cinq
jours plus tard 100 personnes vont se
mettre à manifester les mêmes symptômes
et en plus petites nouveautés dans les
symptômes en a qui en plus de sa faune
des insomnies mais ça va de la petite
insomnies à l'énorme insomnies il ya un
témoignage d'un monsieur qui lui va dire
que son insomnie n a pas duré une nuit
ni deux ni trois est la durée
vingt-et-une lui lui il a fait feu et
une nuits sans dormir rarement tu tu
m'as pète un câble et avoir des
hallucinations à orthez ce mot
hallucinations vous allez voir il va
revenir
bref des dizaines de personnes font des
insomnies normalement pour saint-esprit
c'est une petite ville à 22 heures tous
les gens dorment mais là c'est pas le
cas là tu sors dans les rues et tu peux
croiser beaucoup de gens qui font des
insomnies et qui parle tout seul qui
sont en plein délire et on ne sait pas
pourquoi on sait pas ce qui se passe
petit à petit un autre symptôme fait son
apparition les gens commencent à avoir
des hallucinations certains vont avoir
la sensation de boue
les de l'intérieur et vont se jeter dans
le rhône pour éteindre le feu qui
n'existe pas il y en a plein qui pensent
être capables de voler et qui vont se
jeter de leur fenêtre
bref des hallucinations horrible qui
mènent certains du village à la morgue
la ville et pris de panique le bilan
tout ça c'est 300 personnes comme et des
hallucinations dont sept qui sont mortes
et dont 50 qui ont été interné dans un
hôpital psychiatrique
qu'est ce qui à cause de ça alors face à
ça les médecins ils perdent un peu leurs
moyens et comprennent pas ce qui se
passe
en plus je le rappelle ils sont que 3
l'infrastructure de pont-saint-esprit
avait clairement pas fait pour gérer 300
personnes qui font un bad trip
en même temps cette nuit là les victimes
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses et
en plus elles ont de plus en plus
incontrôlable c'est vraiment des gens
qui sont dans la démence qui délire
totalement qui bouge dans tous les sens
qui hurlent et c'est là que naît le
mystère de pont-saint-esprit il ya donc
une enquête est ouverte et la première
piste qu'on a et découverte par un
professeur de médecine qui était en
vacances au moment des faits qui seront
un pont saint-esprit et qui fait le
rapprochement entre les symptômes des
victimes est une vieille maladie qu'on
surnomme le mal des ardents ou le feu
saint-antoine qui est une maladie qui
date du moyen âge et qui avait
apparemment complètement disparu et
d'ailleurs pas mal de tableau qui
montrent des scènes horrifiques de gens
qui sont victimes de cette maladie là
alors le vrai nom de cette maladie c'est
pas le feu saint-antoine qui est un
surnom parce que les victimes de la
maladie ont l'impression brûlés de
l'intérieur seiler gothisme le
responsable de l'ergot tisme c'est
l'ergot du seigle qui est un champignon
qui va se mettre sur le céréales et
quand tu lingère tu vas avoir des
symptômes très similaires à ceux qu'ont
eue les habitants de la ville de
pont-saint-esprit le 24 août 1951
lankaise a ensuite montré que toutes les
victimes de ces symptômes ont un point
commun elles ont acheté leur pain dans
la même boulangerie est ce que le pain
auraient été confectionnées à partir de
farine contaminés par les herbes hautes
règle c'est possible surtout vu le
contexte on vient de sortir la seconde
guerre mondiale la france elle en pleine
famine c'est une galère de nourrir tout
le monde donc la ressource principale
c'est redevenu le pain cette piste de la
contamination par l'ergot de seigle
semble être la bonne le commissaire 6 go
de la police judiciaire de montpellier
est chargée de l'enquêté
et va donc aller vers la boulangerie qui
semble avoir vendu le pain tous ses
habitants petit bémol les boulangers ne
choisissez pas leur meunier c'est à dire
qu'ils recevaient de la farine d'un
meunier qui leur étaient attitré savait
pas d'où ça venait con c'est pas sa
faute là le commissaire steagall il est
malin il y en a dans le ciboulot il va
retrouver le minotier qui a confectionné
cette farine monsieur mallet il va
l'interroger bien brusquer à tel point
que monsieur mallet va faire des aveux
alors qu'il n'a rien à se reprocher
savez les enquêtes ou c'est très très
médiatisées où il ya beaucoup d'enjeux
on veut absolument trouver un coupable
quitte à ce que quelqu'un fasse
aveux alors que c'est pas lui le
coupable on s'en fout mais il faut
qu'ils aient un coupable aux yeux de la
presse et de la population jusque là
tout va bien le mystère est résolu
sauf que un mois plus tard les
expertises innocente monsieur mallet
parce que les farines ont été analysés
et il n'y a pas d'air go de seigle dans
ces dernières et là c'est très frustrant
parce que la sphère s'arrête là il ya
plein de pistes mais elle mène à rien et
les habitants de pont-saint-esprit n'ont
pas de réponses à leurs questions ils
sont comme des étonnamment on va pas
reparler de la faire pendant 60 ans et
seulement 2010 que quelqu'un va reparler
de la faire et c'est pas un français
c'est un américain qui s'appelle hank
albarelli et qui enquêtent à ce moment
là sur la mort dans les années 50 d'un
biochimiste de la cia
frank olson alors là vous allez me dire
mais où est le rapport lucas on comprend
plus là on sait plus attendait ça arrive
à cyan frank olson qui bossent pour la
cia est un spécialiste des drogues dures
et humaine de nombreuses expériences
pour étudier leurs effets dans le but
d'en tirer profit et comme par hasard
franck s'est rendu en france quelques
mois avant la tragédie de
pont-saint-esprit peu de temps après son
passage en france franck entre dans une
énorme dépression et répète à sa femme
qu'il a commis une terrible erreur et il
décède dans les années 1950 trois sans
qu'on sache ce qui voulait dire par j'ai
commis une terrible erreur peut-être
empoisonné un village qui n'a rien
demandé franck en qui je le rappelle en
quête du coup sûr la mort de frank va
faire un rapprochement et si la cia
avait pulvérisé du lsd sur le pain de
pont-saint-esprit dans le but d'en
étudier les effets à grande échelle je
sais ce que vous pensez des moments ça
vous paraît débile est inconcevable mais
attendez attendez j'ai des infos pour
vous on va rentrer un peu dans la chimie
mais vous allez voir c'est là on se dit
que cette idée elle ne paraît pas si
comme qu'il faut savoir que l'ère god
seigle contient des alcaloïdes dont un
en particulier celui de l'acide
lysergique ça vous dit rien c'est normal
moi aussi mais il faut savoir que le lsd
c'est un dérivé de l'acide lysergique
donc les effets de l'ergot de seigle et
les effets du lsd sont très similaires
ça vous paraît donc moins bête que les
habitants de pont-saint-esprit n'est pas
été empoisonné à l'ergot de seigle mais
est peut-être été droguée au lsd
pourquoi pas mais ça manque de preuves
j'arrive attendait après la seconde
guerre mondiale vous savez c'est la
course à l'armement et à l'arme
nucléaire plus particulièrement parce
qu'on a peur on vit dans la peur d'une
troisième guerre mondiale du coup toutes
les nations du monde veulent être prête
au cas où ya une autre guerre qui arrive
la cia elle va être intéressé par la
manipulation mentale et si on mettait
fin à un conflit sans kit combat juste
en arrivant à convaincre en manipulant
mentalement l'adversaire les us pense
donc que les effets hallucinatoires du
lsd sont la clé de la manipulation
mentale et qui est chargé de tester les
effets du lsd et d'en tirer les
conclusions
frank olson alors je suis d'accord avec
vous
c'est un peu abusé de tester les effets
du lsd sur une ville entière mais il ya
des documents déclassifiés qui montre
qu'en 1950 les etats-unis ont fait des
tests du même genre à san francisco il
ya un navire américain qui a bombardé la
ville pour tester les effets d'une
bactérie a eu douze personnes
hospitalisées dont une qui est morte à
cause de ça tout ça bien sûr dans le but
de se préparer à une éventuelle nouvelle
guerre les enquêteurs qui sont chargés
de l'enquète de pont-saint-esprit font
le rapprochement entre les effets de
l'ergot de seigle et du lsd ils vont
donc contacté le créateur du lsd albert
hofmann pour qu'il vienne à
pont-saint-esprit confirmer si c'est des
effets du lsd ou si c'est des effets de
l'ergot de seigle et devinez quoi
selon lui c'est clairement des symptômes
liés au lsd l'anc est avancé bien c'est
satisfaisant que l'on enquête avance
vous avez vu attendait elle va très vite
arrêté d'avancer quelques jours plus
tard albert hofmann revient sur ses
propos et dit qu'il s'est trompé que
tout ça n'était pas lié au lsd mais à
autre chose
les usa seraient pas mis un petit coup
de pression albert et scalbert c'est
vraiment trompé est ce que c'était
vraiment l'ergot de seigle qui était
responsable de tout ça et pas du lsd
baala bon moment moi je penche plus vers
l'ergot de seigle clairement mais
attendez c'est pas la fin c'est
passionnant sans déconner les folles
cette histoire alors il faut savoir que
la cia pendant des décennies mène un
programme où ils font des expériences
horrible et inhumaine sur des gens
contre leur gré sauf que les expériences
vont mener à rien et que petit à petit
les victimes vont sortir du silence donc
tout le monde va commencer à savoir ce
qui se passe cette situation va obliger
bill clinton en 1995 à faire une
déclaration dans laquelle il s'excuse
auprès de toutes les victimes de ces
programmes se créer à déclassifier des
documents de la cia qui jusqu'à présent
était secret défense devinez qui va
mettre son nez dans ces documents en bas
oui ça a peut-être l'aider à comprendre
comment frank olson est mort en trouve
un document sur lequel on trouve et le
nom de frank olson et dans ce document
de paragraphes parle des événements
tragiques de 1951 de pont-saint-esprit
et tous les paragraphes suivants sont
eux
grimés de noir pour qu'on ne puisse pas
les lire merde alors est ce que c'est un
hasard ou pas qu'un document parle et de
franck qui étudie les effets du lsd et
de la ville de pau saint d'esprit on
sais pas peut-être que franck a tout
simplement été au courant de ce qui
s'est passé à pont-saint-esprit et à
étudier tout ça en se disant c'est du
lsd qui a causé sa on va quand même
regarder les effets que ça a eu même si
ce n'est pas lui qui a donné le
dea pour saint-esprit petite cerise sur
le gâteau ans qui va trouver un autre
document dans lequel un employé du
laboratoire sandoz le laboratoire pour
lequel travaille albert hofmann qui a
découvert les échanges avec un agent
secret américain et dans ce document le
dirigeant du laboratoire aurait avoué
que les événements tragiques de
pont-saint-esprit ne serait pas lié à
l'ergot de seigle mais bel et bien pour
elle ace des fake ou pas fake
on ne saura jamais l'anc est aujourd'hui
s'arrête ici le mystère reste total
et c'est horrible parce qu'il ya quand
même eu des morts c'était vraiment une
catastrophe on se rend pas compte mais
c'était la folie là bas pour
saint-esprit et savait rien de positif
tout ce qui s'est passé déjà la drogue
de base c'est de la merde mais qu'en
plus des drogués à ton insu alors t'as
rien demandé et à des effets mais
hallucinant c'est le cas de le dire
est-ce l'ergot de seigle elle ces
américains qui testait les effets du lsd
à grande échelle
on ne sait pas on a le cul entre deux
chaises comme ceux ci et puis on ne sait
pas bien à qu'elle allait placer la
barre je sais comme moi vous avez envie
d'aller vers la théorie la plus abuser
la plus scandaleuse notre cerveau humain
qui nous fait ça mais il faut rester
objectif en tout cas j'espère que vous
aurez bien tout compris à l'histoire que
j'ai apporté des précisions à ce qui
était déjà au courant de la ferme et
qu'ils n'avaient pas tous les infos en
tout cas j'espère que ça vous a plu
cette histoire n'hésitez pas aimé ce
dossier le cassini 1 serait ni un truc
là j'ai tenté voilà de raconter une
histoire mystérieuse je me suis
documenté comme j'ai pu et je mangeais
était passionné de ce truc là vraiment
je trouve ça génial comme histoire je
fais plein de bisous je vous dis à très
vite dans une prochaine vidéo
peut-être qu'il relate aussi des
histoires mystérieuses comme ça et pas
forcément de ce raid je sais pas c'est
la première peut-être d'une longue série
on sait pas vous dire dire une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien aux oies
[Musique]